quiet and I'm just waiting for you to be
done are you done oh I'm sorry I thought
because you're podcasting talk okay
never mind we talk when we go yeah oh I
know okay well okay you could go
and go and go okay
you guys are idiots
[Laughter]
hey there and welcome to Conan O'Brien
needs a friend as if any of that earlier
stuff is not going to make it in Shawna
was trying to get the last word but
before we started but then I did and um
but you're the mature one it's not like
it matters to you what you had to
mention that you won the important thing
is that I won okay and you lost okay
because I started the podcast before you
could say and go I said it kind of
quietly and you're gonna keep that in
absolutely good yeah you know what's
crazy is that this is how childish I'm a
an elderly man and
but I remember we used to do this thing
at the show at the Late Night show where
I would tag Sona and then head down to
rehearsal and she would tear after me
yes and I would run Full Tilt you would
try and touch me back before I would get
and this is we were we're adults yeah
full-on adults you would lock yourself
in your bathroom in your dressing room
yes and then they'd be telling me you
have to come out and do the show and I'd
say make sure sona's not there so she
can't tag me yeah before what what
someone diagnosed this it's idiocy and
it is really stupid and I won most of
the time that's not true that's not true
I know it's not yeah who which one of
you is more pathetic I'm gonna say me oh
no come on it's not fun when we agree no
it's definitely me I'm older I was the
host of the show and I used to try and
think of ways that I could be assured of
a win I thought once of putting a mild
acid in a squirt gun and firing it at
you if you got too close like a mild
acid they would just create like a first
or second degree burn maybe a third well
we've always been like very brother
sister and Danny and I used to do this
where you know my mom be like don't
don't hit your sister and usually he'll
be like he'll put his finger an inch
away from my arm and you'd be like I'm
not touching her I'm not touching her
and it would absolutely drive me insane
yeah I think it's it's definitely a
brother sister thing and uh I I have the
tease Gene I like to what I'm sorry this
is a big coming out for me but I do like
to were you also a G's team
well often yes
starting at around 15 yes uh anyway the
point being that I it's definitely me
I'm the pathetic one it was my problem
it was up to me to be the mature person
and of course I couldn't do it yeah so
Sona I'll take the fall for that one I
don't know if duck give it to him I'm
not I'm not doing it as a passive
aggressive move I'm saying you know you
are no I'm not yes you are until you
acquiesce then he'll make it passive
aggressive no I'll be the I'm the
pathetic one I'm pathetic all right okay
you're smiling at yourself you're so
proud of you and happy with yourself if
you could just put her saying on the
pathetic one on a huge Echo so it
reverberates I'd be quite happy normally
I do not Grant these requests but that
one I will take it away
down anyway